Vice President Mike Pence participated
in a disgusting vile disrespectful and
totally wasteful stunt over the weekend
and because of Donald Trump's tweets we
know that it was deliberately staged
vice president Mike Pence decided to go
to an NFL football game on Sunday
great Indianapolis Colts vs. San
Francisco 49ers in Indiana some players
kneeled during the national anthem and
we've been seeing this go on for weeks
across the NFL even dating back to last
season Mike Pence left immediately after
that instead of staying for the game why
Mike Pence said he couldn't support the
event after players protested in that
manner and Mike Pence condemned the
protests in a statement apparently we
were led to believe Mike Pence was just
so shocked so stunned that 49ers players
would do this oh wait now it was all
planned and the 49ers players have been
doing this for more than a year it was
not a spur-of-the-moment move by Mike
Pence to show support for the flag or
whatever it is he thinks he was
supporting we learned from ESPN that
when Mike Pence arrived at the stadium
the reporters were told stay right by
the stadium because Mike Pence is going
to be leaving the game early it was
discovered that Mike Pence had plans to
attend a fundraiser in California the
timing of which would have made it
impossible for pens to state for the
entire game pence was scheduled to be
back in California for 6:30 p.m. and the
entire thing was staged at your expense
at taxpayer dollars expense Donald Trump
went on Twitter and said quote I asked
vice president pens to leave the stadium
if any players kneeled disrespecting our
country I am proud of him and second
lady Karen pence of course it was known
that this was going to happen at this
game 49ers players have been doing this
since last season traffic was tied up
people were inconvenienced for this
political stunt and what did it cost at
minimum a quarter of a million dollars
in taxpayer money
for Mike Pence to show up and leave in
protest after kneeling and that's
minimum probably more if you account for
all the costs and disruption that were
caused by this but we never have money
right slow response to Puerto Rico we
can't do it faster no resources for
health care for all can't afford it and
I get it it's two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars but I thought they were
FISA fiscally conservative my instinct
is to call it a cheap political stunt
it's really an expensive political stunt
it is so dumb that it is beyond parody
and satire it's really tragic and the
statement that pence put out said in
part I left today's Colts game because
POTUS and I will not dignify any event
that disrespects our soldiers our flag
or our national anthem
you were vice president to a guy who
mocked a prisoner of war John McCain you
were vice president to a guy who
insulted the parents of a soldier who
died in combat but it's disrespectful
to peacefully kneel during the national
anthem Mike Pence is effectively a paid
protester here supposedly football games
weren't the places for political
protests that's effectively what Mike
Pence did here and you paid for it you
paid for it with taxpayer dollars and
just as a little reminder right the
troops fight so that we can protest
peacefully with full free speech not for
right-wing political correctness that
says you're not allowed to kneel during
the national anthem or in front of the
flag and the bigger trend here by the
way I do want to talk about the the jet
travel thing rich Trump administration
members wasting your money on jet
airplane travel Tom Price resigned over
this Stephen minuchin doing lots of the
same stuff Mike Pence traveling around
on Air Force two or whatever plan it is
to protest the NFL but don't worry
trump's gonna fix the problem of fiscal
responsibility right and drain the swamp
what during his next golf match or
whatever and I think it's time for
people to stop speaking for the veterans
like the veterans are treated like
there's some kind of singular unit
form group I spoke to some vets over the
weekend they didn't all have the same
opinion about the kneeling but they all
had the same opinion about being used as
political footballs it's disrespectful
to the troops says who they fight so
that they can defend partially our
ability to protest and express our views
however it is that we want provided that
it's not violent and as a reminder civil
rights protests have never been popular
Trump and his cronies are touting hey
most of the country agrees with Trump's
view on the protests or whatever find
any major civil rights protest that at
the time was popular I'll wait
you really can't and meanwhile Puerto
Rico is still without power in many
parts something like 17 or 18 percent of
the island has power yet Pence is
jetting around for political stunts
expensive political stunts absolutely
disgusting absolutely and totally
disgusting hey this Thursday I'll be
speaking at Worcester State University
at 10:00 a.m. open to the public I'll be
speaking about media literacy critical
thinking and climate change
you can Google David Pakman Worcester
State University October 12 for details
would love to see some of you there we
will take a break I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's program made
possible in part by wink if I were given
the task of picking out a wine that I
was going to like with the catch that it
couldn't be a bottle of wine that I had
tried before I wouldn't know where to
start because I'm clueless about wine
that's where wink comes in spell the
winc wink makes it easy to discover
great wines every month they ship you
wines that have been matched to your
taste and personalized to you through
what they call their palate profile quiz
so you can go to try wink comm slash
Pakman and again that's WI and see
you'll get asked just a few simple
questions how do you like your coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and a few other questions and using
those answers the wink system will match
you to great wines you haven't tried
before
personalized to you and delivered right
to your door as you drink more wines and
rate them yes or no yay or nay I like or
don't like
wink will learn and continue to send you
new personalized delicious wines for the
next month no membership fees you can
skip any delivery that you want cancel
anytime and wink has a 100% satisfaction
guarantee so you'll never have to pay
for a bottle you don't like and for a
limited time our viewers and listeners
can get $20 off when you go to try wink
comm slash Pakman that's tri wink
spelled T ry winc comm /p a que ma n for
$20 off that's tri wink comm slash
Pakman